bonjour hugo salle et steve aujourd'hui
je vais faire un vidéo donc en français
parce que je vais discuter avec hugo
coton et en français je ne vais pas
faire de sous titres en anglais nés de
traduction alors pour mes spectacles
comment dit-on pour les candidats
spectateurs les spectateurs mais vous
avez la possibilité donc avec les sous
titres d' importer toute la discussion a
link pour étudier cela est mieux
comprendre et apprendre quelques mots et
les expressions en français
hugo est ce que tu peux nous raconter
ton activité ce que tu fais à le butin
où es tu es présence sur les médias
sociaux
ok alors moi ça fait cinq ans que
j'habite en pologne à varsovie et
je suis arrivé là bas un peu par hasard
et je suis devenu prof de français par
hasard
également parce que pendant mes études
j'ai étudié le commerce dans une école
de commerce à paris
donc a priori ça n'avait rien à voir
avec l'enseignement j'ai déménagé à
varsovie avec un ami pour créer un
business qui n'a pas du tout marché
mais comme j'avais envie de rester sur
place je suis allé toquer à la porte de
l'institut français et là ils m'ont
proposé d'animer un cours de
conversation et dès les premiers cours
j'ai complètement pris goût j'ai adoré
ça le contact avec les élèves
la transmission de connaissances j'ai
trouvé ça vraiment génial
donc j'ai décidé de m'investir un peu
plus là dedans en fait je me suis formé
sur le tas comme on dit en français donc
en apprenant en travaillant en lisant
des livres etc
et puis au bout de deux ou trois ans je
me suis rendu compte qu'il y avait
vraiment un problème pour les étudiants
intermédiaire parce que c'est très
difficile de trouver des contenus qu'ils
soient intéressants qu'ils soient
différents de camille va s'acheter un
pain au chocolat à la boulangerie mais
qu'ils soient accessibles parce qu'en
fait il n'y a pas vraiment de contenus
entre les contenus pour les débutants et
les contenus pour les natifs
si je peux être un terreau offre ce mois
seulement le cas pour le français c'est
le cas pour toutes les langues
il ya un écart énorme entre l'élève et
continue pour débutants et puis pouvoir
accéder à des choses vraiment
intéressantes mais qui sont souvent à
trop difficile et à ce moment là j'ai
découvert un taux de caste parce que
j'apprenais le polonais
un podcast qui s'appelle huile riche
donc je crois en tout cas mais voilà et
j'ai trouvé que c'était génial de son
podcast et c'est vraiment grâce à lui en
fait que j'ai commencé à avoir une bonne
compréhension du polonais a vraiment
prendre goût l'apprentissage du polonais
je me suis dit que ça serait génial de
faire la même chose pour le français
parce qu'à ma connaissance il n'y avait
pas de podcasts similaires donc c'est ce
que j'ai fait j'ai lancé un podcast
français intermédiaire donc c'était moi
s'appelle comment s'appellent ces
podcasts donc au départ ça s'appelait
quand hong un jeu de mot entre mon nom
de famille et le motegi
donc maintenant il ya plein de personnes
qui me demandent mais qu'est ce que
c'est le coton caisse casser le côté
gore français parce qu'il cherche dans
le dictionnaire est évidemment il trouve
pas voilà c'est un jeu de mots est donc
géré nommer un peu pour que ce soit plus
clair et maintenant ça s'appelle tout
simplement intermediate french podcasts
et tout ça c'est sous la marque indoor
french
donc si vous tapez in french vous allez
trouver ma chaîne youtube
le podcast c'est ok je vais essayer de
mettre sur le vidéo donc le lien ton
podcast est ce que tu offres aussi
d'aider transcrit des textes exactement
donc c'est ça en fait qui
qui a vraiment plu aux gens c'est que
geoffrey les transcriptions gratuitement
sur mon site c'est toujours le cas
d'ailleurs donc pour chaque épisode il
ya une inscription complète les épisodes
durent une trentaine de minutes parce
que je pense que c'est important de
vraiment se plonger dans la langue et
avec un podcast de dix minutes quand on
est débutant ce c'est mieux mais je
pense qu'au niveau intermédiaire on a
vraiment besoin de se mettre dans le
bain comme on dit oui donc voilà c'est
des podcasts assez longs les
transcriptions également mais voilà il
ya les transcriptions gratuite sur mon
site
est ce que c'est des podcasts avec vidéo
dans des interviews ou est ce que c'est
des monologues ou des quoi s'agit-il
donc en fait c'est des monologues
je prends des sujets qui m'intéressent
tout simplement et j'en parle pendant
une trentaine de minutes
pour moi c'est génial aussi parce que ça
me permet parfois de faire des
recherches supplémentaires d'approfondir
certains sujets et puis en école de
commerce
on apprend justement à vendre a présenté
et c'est donc c'est une compétence que
j'avais développé en école de commerce
et voilà c'est quelque chose que je
réutilise maintenant en tant que prof
je crois que c'est assez c'est le genre
de contenu que tout le monde cherche
pour moi par exemple
et évidemment il ya un écart énorme
entre les laisse pas ce qu'on appelle
nous les mini story ce qui est un peu ce
que fait piotr c'est à dire beaucoup de
répétitions à l'intérieur de la même
histoire et beaucoup de verts surtout de
haute fréquence et entre ça et japonais
je les entends turc en persan et en
arabe comprend très bien et quand je
veux j'écoute par exemple des
discussions sur france 24
alarab c'est trop difficile il n'y a pas
de transcription donc j'ai essayé avec
des sites autour de transcription et
cetera et cetera très fiable donc mais
je crois que nos membres allaient que
pourrait importer enfin pour leur propre
compte parce que là c'est quand même si
c'est toi tu as les droits là dessus
peut-être qu'on pourrait mettre quelques
échantillons ali pour les athées attiré
la foule
pour les gens qui vont donc se chercher
des podcasts ils peuvent importer et le
sombre et le texte pour l'étudier en
profondeur et d'ailleurs je crois que ça
serait une initiative non seulement pour
le français mais pour d'autres membres
s'il y avait davantage de gens qui
faisait ce genre de choses évidemment
cet idéal s'il ya un dialogue en un
homme et une femme par exemple
mais même les monologues si le contenu
est intéressant
si les gens ont des choses à dire et ils
font un peu de recherche comme tu dis
ces cdd chose idéale parce que quand tu
parles là normalement tu pense à des
choses du parc peut sans avoir écrit au
préalable
et forcément tu utilise un vocabulaire
qui est quand même dire est pas simple
mais moins de mots recherchés - deux
mots difficiles est donc cet idéal
justement pour le ce niveau
intermédiaire donc félicitations
effectivement régulièrement il ya des
gens qui me demandent 'est-ce que tu
connais la même chose un podcast
similaire en espagnol en anglais
et voilà je crois qu'il ya vraiment un
besoin pour ça et une demande et je sais
qu'il par exemple je crois qu'en en
espagnol y en a un qui s'appelle not
seen spanish et un couple justement qui
parlent ensemble donc il ya une
dimension un peu plus interactive mais
ce que j'ai découvert aussi c'est que
contrairement aux méthodes comme à 6000
par exemple avec ses dialogues qui sont
un peu fictif un peu artificielle là moi
comme je parle de sujets qui
m'intéressent que les gens accrochent
aussi au côté un peu plus personnel ils
ont l'impression de développer une
relation avec moi et ça ça les motive
vraiment et je sais qu'il ya des gens
qui en deux ou trois semaines ont déjà
écouté 30 épisodes donc ça fait 15
heures de français et il
ils se rendent même pas compte en fait
qu'ils font c'est qu'ils font des
efforts et qu'ils apprennent la langue
parce que ils y prennent du plaisir et
hollande à 6000 qui est très coté parlée
par les glaces etc
mais je trouve que les contenus là
dans les séries à 6100 quand même c'est
pas idéal parce que ça commence
c'est parler très lentement et cccb
continue sans intérêt il vit ça
progresse très vite et c'est ya souvent
des contenus un peu exotique culturel je
sais pas quoi et pas très intéressant
mais trop vite alors que l'idée m'en
dans les ministres de ce qui nous avons
on est à peu près d'un an au même niveau
pendant 60 à part l'impression de
commencer par quelque chose de très
simple pour ensuite progresser à quelque
chose de très d'inaccessible c'est plus
ou moins toujours au même niveau et si
tu peux maintenir dans des discussions
des monologues intermédiaire toujours au
même niveau
ça permet d'approfondir justement sa
capacité c'est dans ce set banda
d'intermédiaire mais par la suite on
peut aller chercher des audio livres à
n'importe quoi quand je crois que c'est
une bonne initiative et peut-être que
nous qui faisons ce genre de contenu
l'espagnol celui qui fait le couple qui
fait ça et toi et moi et d'autres ça
devrait devenir un espèce de mouvement
parce que c'est beaucoup plus utile que
tous les cours qui réinvente la
grammaire des explications un peu
différent de ce qu'ils avaient avant
mais tout c'est toujours la même chose
c'est la langue mais ce qui manque c'est
exactement ce que tu fais est ici à
moyens de coopérer et pour nous bien sûr
un mix de plus il ya de ce genre de
contenu plus à des des sources ou non
membres peuvent aller à importer à
utiliser maintenant j'ai aussi de plus
en plus souvent des profs de français
qui me contactent en disant que qu'ils
aimeraient faire un peu la même chose
qu'ils aimeraient lancer leurs podcasts
c'est moi je trouve ça génial parce que
voilà il ya plein de place
pour ce genre de contenu et plus il y en
aura plus ça sera facile pour les gens
parce que moi j'ai aussi ma personnalité
j'ai certaines idées politiquement je
suis plutôt de gauche et les je m'en
cache pas et ça ça se voit parfois dans
le traitement de certains sujets je sais
qu'il ya des gens à qui ça plaît pas
peut-être et ce serait bien qu'ils aient
voilà d'autres points de vue d'autres
personnalités et plus on aura mieux ça
sera pour les apprentis en train
d'apprendre ce n'est pas nécessairement
offre la possibilité d'apprendre la
langue pas forcément de convaincre mais
les auditeurs de ton point de vue non
c'est vrai mais comme j'y mets un peu de
moi dans chaque jouet mais c'est normal
que voilà mais ça c'est ce qui rend la
les podcasts authentique
exactement c'est très bon ok bah merci
beaucoup et je crois que pour nos
auditeurs téléspectateurs
c'est très important de savoir qui a qui
est des sources comme ça donc je vais le
publier
c'est un peu plus un peu de publicité
mettre le lien et c'est ingrat j'espère
que davantage de gens avant de découvrir
et je trouve que c'est une initiative
excellente
merci vous contrôle interne ainsi
beaucoup steve merci hockey au revoir au
revoir
ok je laisse l'enregistrement et après
on pourra faire le montage parce que je
sais pas si on peut avoir deux fichiers
sur la même conversation ou alors
peut-être que j'arrête l'enregistrement
on ferme
zoom oui à le premier fichier et je
t'envoie une autre invitation excellent
excellent ok c'est bon maillage sur ok
ouais
[Musique]